the Somme was completed before the
president United States pulled the the
country out of the Paris climate climate
agreements you had some conversations
with him before that happened what gives
you some optimism that the president and
his cabinet which is filled with climate
change deniers can somehow do something
positive to turn the tide I tried hard
to convince Donald Trump before the
inauguration and after he got to the
White House to come to his senses on the
Paris agreement and I actually thought
there was reason to hope after my
exchanges with him that he would but I
but I was wrong
the rogues gallery of climate deniers
around him I think stopped that so we're
just going to have to work around him
and the good news is that there's a law
of physics that sometimes works in
politics for every action there is an
equal and opposite reaction and out in
the country right now there is a huge
reaction to what he's doing
and on the climate movement has more
momentum and enthusiasm and passion now
than I've ever seen and what Bonnie and
John have done with this movie my
dearest hope is that people will see it
and the more people who do the more the
movement will gain momentum so I'm very
optimistic I think we're going to win
this and after he pulled out of Paris I
was fearful that other countries might
use that as an excuse to do the same but
instead the entire rest of the world
redoubled its commitment to the Paris
agreement as if to say will show you
Donald wrong and and here here in the US
governor's and mayors and business
leaders have stepped up to fill the gap
and said we're still in and by the way
your Governor Jerry Brown is a real hero
on this and
now it looks like the US has a real
chance of meeting the commitments in
spite of Donald Trump Jeff I want to ask
about participants view in this position
in all this because you obviously worked
on the original film why did you feel it
was time 11 years later to come back and
revisit what Davis Guggenheim had
started with an inconvenient truth
well first off a big thank you to all of
you here tonight
coming up for this film the original
film was built on the shoulders of all
of those in the Academy and all of those
who did an inconvenient truth in the
first place like Davis Guggenheim who
directed the film and all through the
years
Davis along with our producers Laurie
David and Lawrence bender and Scott
Burns and and others unless they choked
up we would talk it is now a time to
come back and tell the world what has
happened because before the first film
came out Americans didn't care so much
about climate change and a couple of
years after it came out Americans cared
a lot the recession hit the deniers
gotten here and was no is that really
the time to come back and say what
happened well we tried in different ways
finally in April of 2015
al had come to my office a participant
and we were sitting together and saying
al is now the time for sequel and I'll
said you know it's been 10 years well
very wise they said you know this is a
10 year anniversary and this movie this
film had such a touch point in the world
and I'd like to get that message out to
the people that we talked to that what
the scientist said what the people said
what those results were and whether we
were right whether we were not right
what happened and also is there a new
story to tell and I said I agree
completely and there's this whole new
world of clean tech that you saw in the
film I work in my day job much of the
time in the clean tech and so I see that
these things are coming we're on the
precipice of a new generation of clean
energy for everyone so Al and I said you
know what now is the time to make the
film and I just have one promise what
one won't ask really let's not
make a political film it's about what
happened to climate and the clean tech
revolution remember we saw most of this
prior to the u.s. election so all I
could say is politics happens but the
clean tech revolution is upon us and Al
has been leading us all the way through
John and Bonnie how did you approach
this as a film that would both extend
the conversation that was started 11
years ago with the first film and make a
new conversation happen as well what was
the continuation and what was the new
thought that you brought to the making
of your film let's start well of course
we were you know so honored to get this
call from Diane wireman that have Jeff's
documentary department at participant we
we went to Nashville in July a couple
years ago almost exactly two years ago
we sat down without he was gracious
enough to give us the ten hour version
of his slide show I'll be showing that
later and Bonnie and I we had we had
worked on a climate film called the
island president but thank you about
four or five years ago and so we felt
like we knew kind of the basics but we
really learned a lot that day and one
thing we learned a lot as you just saw
about the about just how bad things have
gotten and of course how much hope there
is and the sustainability markets now
but we also just felt Al's energy and we
kind of looked at each other and we
thought if we could do a Verret a film a
cinema verite film where we were kind of
flies on the wall that sort of harkens
back to you know the way documentaries
were done back in the day which is of
course a format that we love to work and
we thought if we could capture that and
we looked at Al scheduled for the year
we thought oh god the Paris climate
Accords this is happening later this
year about that that seems pretty
interesting and we started thinking in
those terms and towards of sort of
building a documentary screenplay over
the course of the next 18 months Bonnie
how would you say that you cast the
planet in this film and how important
was it to get citizen journalists to be
involved much the way that their
reporting of what's happening in Syria
to document what's happening around
around the world
so planet Earth was really obviously the
major character
in this film and it was incredibly
important to us to make sure that the
cinematography reflected that that
whenever you see something of Earth it
is in its all its majestic beauty to
start out with but often like you see in
Greenland you're sort of you know you're
experiencing one of the wonders of the
world but then all of a sudden as we
pull up and John it's also the
cinematographer of this film and we had
some drones in Greenland that kind of
lifted up and you started to see the
cracks in the ice and kind of the virus
that that is taking over this wonder of
the world so we we looked for ways to
cinematically to show that dissonance
that was very important to us
and another key character in the film
was all the user-generated video from
citizens around the world who are
experiencing climate disasters a very
good example of this would be when we
did the research for the terrible storm
that hit Tacloban in the Philippines and
had a picture that and Richard was
responsible for a huge amount of this
research and collection but we wanted to
see what kind of user-generated videos
we could find on the Internet of people
who had been in the middle of the storm
trying to save people in fact the mayor
of Tacloban that video that you see
where he's pushing through the ceiling
to find dry ground that was his he was
taking it in the moment so people around
the world are feeling this it's
emotional for them and they're the small
the small acts of citizen journalism are
actually collectively having one voice
that we can all respond to Richard you
accompany these filmmakers to Paris and
part of the nature of the story is we're
going to follow the vice-president
around and the Vice President is meeting
with some very interesting and
high-profile people so you've got your
camera crew and then there's maybe a
head of state that wanders into the
frame what are the conversations that
you're having in real time to make sure
that your cameras are getting where the
Vice President is getting and you're
getting access to those conversations I
guess part of my job was to go into the
men's room and to see you with the
leaders were coming it going to be
coming out of it but
but now we were in in in Paris there's a
kind of inner sanctum that we had a path
to get into and it was amazing to see
you know
bonkie moon walk by and president
Hollande walked by and in obviously the
former vice president is completely
comfortable with these people and they
love to see him and it wasn't it wasn't
hard to necessarily arrange these
meetings I mean you see in the film
Justin Trudeau and Trudeau comes up and
and introduces himself as as if mr. Gore
doesn't know who he is and and it was
like that time and time again one of the
one of the moments that I thought was
particularly funny I didn't have to do
it that's where leaders was he would be
mobbed constantly and I remember you
saying these are my peeps
it's my demo and there were everywhere
we went people want to take selfies and
and it made you realize that the United
States is so unique in terms of this
polarization over the climate that
around the world there seems to be much
more consensus that we need to do
something about it and but we were we
were making our way to a hallway and
it's got to be so many people that
former vice president jumped into the
swedish off at the side days and they
were surprised to see you what is he
doing in there and quickly the kind of
the crowd dissipated and we've reached
into the into the hallway what can
people do leaving this theater what can
they do give them five things that's
going to help turn the tide use your
voice use your vote use your choices in
life your voice is important to win the
conversations about climate these other
revolutions that were referred to in the
movie were won in conversations before
the actual laws changed if somebody had
told me even five years ago that in the
year 2017 gay marriage would be legal in
all 50 states and accepted honored
celebrated by more than two-thirds of
the American people I would have said I
sure hope so but that seems impossible
but it happened because people created a
social revolution in consciousness and
awareness so use your voice including on
social media and using your vote also
means communicating with your elected
officials and the candidates who
approach you when enough people say
passionately this is important to you it
changes use your choices in life you've
made such choices a new electric car
just came out for $35,000 yesterday
there are companies in California who
will put solar panels all over your roof
for free and your bills will go down 20%
the next day the choices are becoming
available now and when you make the
right ones that sends a powerful message
to business and industry and for those
of you who like this movie please use
word of mouth to recommend it to others
because the more people who see this the
more this movement will gain momentum
[Applause]